それでは正堂にご登場いただきます
皆さんは大きな拍手でお迎えください
はい それから講演に入ります
ちょっと長い時間しゃべることになりますが
大変よろしくお願いいたします
あの今日はね 本当に素晴らしいところで
こんなに気持ちのいい心穏やかになる心を落ち着く
場所で私も説法をあまりしたことがないんです
まあ究極で 現代的なコンクリートで固まっているのも
これもコンクリートかもしれませんだけど
固まっているところでなんとか喋ってみましたけど
しかし 我々人間というのは
まあ自然の出来物だからね
自然の中でいるとすごい気持ちがいいんです
やっぱりさすが日本の神道の神社っていうところは
この自然の恵み 自然のありがたさ
自然のこの心と体をね
治して癒してくれる この元々の環境派を真剣に大事に守っているんです
そういうことで この神宮大社の建物で
宮司様も大変心掛けて
ありがたくどうぞ使ってくださいということで貸してくれたことはとても深く感謝いたします
それから我々みんな その穏やかな雰囲気の中で
自然の波動そのまま残っているこの雰囲気の中で
ブッダの話をありがたく聞いて理解することを考えてみましょう
それでは いろいろテーマ
皆様の提案がございましたけど
その中でなんとかまとめて一つ決めました
私は私とは何者？という
残念ながらこのテーマの説明はなんかすっごくややこしくて難しくなるんです
このスライド ちょっとよく見える方々はよく見てください
あまり私の目みたいになって
あまり文字が見えない方々は別に気になさなくても構いません
スライドを見てもかなり難しいと感じる可能性あります
だからあまり気にしないで
気軽に聞いてみてください
難しいと思ったら私はすぐ話を変えます
変えてわかりやすくするようにします
それからこの私が別なコンピューターで作ったスライドでありまして
これが別の他のコンピューターで映したりすると文字化けしたりがします
だからそこら辺は無視するんです
それから私はあんまり勢いで
このちょっと 30 分ぐらいで作りましたので
打ち間違いは結構十分ほどあります
まあ二度と見てないんです
もうちゃんと打ってるのか
正しい漢字で出ているのかどうか
まあそういうところを見つけたらまた無視してください
なかったことにしてください
そうするしかないんです
では 私は何者？という
これは仏教である大きな問題なんですよ
なぜかというと 我々にあなたはこうしなさい
こうしなさいとか 人間たるものこういうふうに生きるべきだよとかね
神様は信じるべきだよとか
あるいは神様は信じるものじゃないんだよと色々言いますよ
みんな 死んだらどうするんでしょうかね？とかね
死んだらどうもする必要はないんですけど
死んだんだから でもやっぱり悩んじゃうんですね
死んだらどうすればいいんでしょうか？とか
死ぬ前にやるべきことをやっておいた方がいいんですけど
それから私は本当に死んだらどこかに行くんでしょうかとか
ただお墓の中でずっといる羽目になるんでしょうかとかね
そういういろんなことを我々は考えてはいるんです
これは人類の初めから
そんなことでどうすればいいか
どうすればいいか どうすればいいかと
そんなことばっかして
それどうなったかというと
ある人はこうしなさいというと
ある人はこうしなさいという
ある人はもう茎をしたり
断食をしたり 滝行をやったり
もう心清らかにしたり
いろんなことをした方がいい
ある人はせっかく短い人生だから
よく食べて飲んでね まあ遊んで生活しちゃえばいいのに
死んじゃったら全部死体になって灰になるんだからと
それいろんなことを言うんですよ
どちらですればいいんですか？ってわからないんです
誰が正しいかはわからないんです
そういうことで 我々が宗教の話を聞けば聞くほど
頭がおかしくなるんですよ
学校に行って先生からね
道徳の話なんか今はもう入れてくれませんだけど
子供たちかわいそうですよ
もう学校に行って道徳の授業とかなんとか受けてみちゃうと
今まであった道徳観まで消えてしまっちゃって
もうとんでもないことになってしまいますよ
だから結局は人の話聞けば聞くほどわからなくなる
宗教なんか勉強すればするほど
なおさらわからなくなっちゃって
もうそういうことになっているのは事実です
それでお釈迦様がちょっと待ってください
大きな問題があるんじゃないかと
私はどうするべきかと考える以前に
一体絶対私って何者かと
それわかっちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
私って何者かとわかってしまえば
もう人から話を聞く必要ないんです
自分でわかるんです どうすればいいかっていうことは
そういうことで 仏教の特色というか
テーマが宗教のテーマと違います
大失礼すみません だから我々にとっては
まあこういう神社だけではなくて
教会でも説法できます
別にそちらの教えと全然関係ないんだから
反対することも賛成することもないんです
そのおっしゃっていることはどうかなと理解するために
先に私は何者かと理解した方がいいんです
でもこれってすごく難しいんです
そういうことだから で
面識のない自分に初めて会ってみます
人のは面識ありますけど
自分自身に会ったことがないんです
だからブッダは自分自身に会わせてくれるんです
私 唯一な存在ということで
私たちは自分がたった一つの大事な存在だと思ってるんです
私が偉いと だから私のことを調べる必要ないんだと
私にいちいちいろんなことをガチャガチャ言うなよと
でも私はみんなにいっぱい言いますよと
という人は誰でもやってますよ
自分が堂々と胸を張るか
人に説教しますけど 自分に何か言われるとすごく嫌な顔するんです
で 最近うちの子どもたちをちょっと見てみましたけど
あの ギャーギャーとお父さんにお母さんにいろんなこれは違うんじゃないか
違うんじゃないかと随分厳しいことを言うんです
両親がちょっとそれ間違ってる
ちょっとどうかなといったところで怒るんです
子どものくせに どう見ても自分たちやっていることは完全間違いなんですけど
だから子どもでさえ他人に説教したいと思っていて
自分に説教されるとすごく嫌がるんですよ
これは誰でも同じなんです
ですから 私たちは自分がすごく唯一な
もう偉い存在だと思っているんです
たった一人しかない自分だけの存在だとすると
自分のこと以外何も知ることはできなくなるんです
これ 結果どうなるのかというと
私こそが偉い 私こそ偉いと思っているんだから
人のこと知らなくてもいいんだ
大した人じゃないんだからね
だからお嫁さんもらったら
姑さんが初めから私だけ偉かったんだからということで
姑お嫁さんに対してすごい態度を取るんです
だからお嫁さんのことさっぱりわからなくなっちゃうんです
理解しようともしないんです
両親がね 自分たちが偉いんだから
あんまり子供たちのことを理解しようとしないんです
それでお互い様 戦々恐々
全く知ることなく生活する羽目になるんです
だから私がすごい偉いと思ってしまった時点で
我々大きな失敗するんです
他人のことを知らなくなるんです
面白いことをこの 20年
25年  30年 夫婦生活しているんですけど
奥さんは全然旦那のことを知らないんです
旦那様は奥さんのことを知らないんです
何考えてるのかとか 好き嫌いは何なのかとか
何に従っているのかとか
全然わからないんです
そういう人生になるんです
私は生きている 他の生命も生きている
私も無数の生命の中で一つの生命であると見るべきです
これブッダの教え だから
まあそんな自分がそんな偉そうなことじゃないんだと
私も生きている生き物で
みんなまあ生きている生き物であると
だからもう無数の生命がいるんだと
本当のところはもうまだまだ暑いんだからね
ちょっと外を出たらアリがいるわね
虫たちがいるわ 人間の数よりはるかに多いんですね
虫とかアリとかね みんな生命なんです
だから一切の生命の中で
私もたった 1個の生命ですと
これ出しゃばって威張るものじゃないんだと
と思うのは仏教の世界なんです
傲慢張らないんです 例えば海がありますね
海っていうのは地球の 4分の3ぐらい海だから
すごい大きいんですよ
海っていうのはどう見ても水一滴一滴でできていますね
海水ですけど 一滴一滴で海ができています
海はものすごい大きいかもしれませんけど
自分がその一滴の水のような存在です
それで海の中で 生活している
だから海で言うならば大丈夫です
何の問題もないんです
自分だけ 一滴の水だけ出しゃばって威張って
俺が偉いぞと思っちゃっても話にならないんです
俺がこのこんな他の海水と一緒にいたくないんだと飛び上がっちゃうとどうなるかというと蒸発してしまいます
だから この一切の生命の中で
たった一人の生命だと
たった一個の生命だと思ってしまえば
それから生きることはもうものすごく楽になるんです
結局 わざわざ苦労して
ストレスかかってかかって
いろんなことをしなくてもいいんです
例えば 海の海水が海の海水通していると
波が現れようが 津波になろうがあんまり苦労しないんですよ
そういうふうに楽にいられます
一滴だけ出しゃばって自我を張ろうとしちゃうと潰されるだけ
ですから 我々は精神的にそう思うべきなんです
すべての生命の中で たった一個の生命ですということを
えーと いっぱい この浜辺
浜辺というんですか  海岸でね
ものすごい大量に砂があるんですね
一滴一粒の砂であると
自分から だから自分にとっては砂と一緒にいた方がなんとかいいじゃないですかね
一粒の砂には何のこともできんだからね
何のこともできん そういうことで私が偉いと思うことよりは
お釈迦様は言うのは あんたは多数の無数の無制限の生命の中で
たった一つの生命であると
智慧のある人は生命 生きることは何かと理解するんです
それからまあ一つの水一滴かもしれませんよ
自分が砂一粒の砂かもしれませんよ
でも ちょっと頭のある人がね
物事を考える人は その生命
生きるということはどういうことだ
つまらないんですね ただ
自分が水は海の一滴の水だと思って
巨大な海の中でいたってもいなくても
全然さっぱりわかりもしないんですね
それで考えてやっても
あまり面白くはないんですよ
楽に生きられますけど
ですから 生きるといは何なのかと考えなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことで 命って何でしょうか？と発見するんです
今すぐものすごい速いスピードで発見しています
自分と死体を比較します
自分は生きている 死体は生きていない
この差を見つければ それが生きることです
それで仏教はあまり神秘的な説明を認めません
神々の話も 神が作ったれこれ
そういう話もあまり当てにしない
仏教はあくまでも科学的に物事を見る
だから命って何だろう
命って何だろう 命って何だろうという問題に誰も答えがないでしょう
仏教はでは何とかしましょう
それで死体を持ってくるんです
死んだもの 死体と自分が比較してみるんです
そうすると まずわかることは死体は生きていない
自分が生きている では
この死体と私が何が違うの？と調べるんです
そう調べると命というものを発見します
例えばこの差は 自分が呼吸している
話している 食事取る 心臓が動いて血液が流れている
排泄している 歩いたり座ったり寝たりしているなどなどですね
自分がいっぱいことをやってますよ
喋っているは 立っているは座っているは
見たり聞いたりしているわ
ご飯食べたりするわ それから食べたものを飲んだものを排泄したりするわ
心臓がドキンドキンと動いているわ
血液が流れているわ 呼吸しているわ
ものすごい仕事をしています
死体は何もしていないんです
だからその機能が生きるということなんです
単純ですよ 全然神秘的じゃないんです
要するに生きることは動きなんです
要するに動いてます 呼吸しているということは動いていること
喋っているということは動いていること
座るということは動いていること
何でも動いていること
例えば皆様が顕微鏡で細胞を見てください
生きている細胞は動いているんです
一番いい例は このアメーバという一個の細胞の生命がいるんですね
アメーバ アメーバは目で見えませんが
あまりに小さい細胞一つしかないんだから
それで学校なんかではこの顕微鏡の中に入れて見るんです
見てすぐわかります アメーバ生きてるかないかということは
生きているアメーバはぐにゃぐにゃ
ぐにゃぐにゃ ぐにゃぐにゃ動いているんです
死んだアメーバはそのまんまペターッと
何の動きもないんです
だから生きている 生きるということは動きですよ
それは全く不思議なことじゃないんです
まあかっこいい言葉 私も使いますけど
これはこのダイナミズムですよ
もう大変すぐ動いている
そこに動きなんですよ
それで動きが命っていうことにしましょう
例えば 今皆様がね 頭をかいたり
手を上げたり スクリーンを見たりするでしょう
結構動いてます ということは生きていることなんです
それが生きていることで
それが命なんです 絶えず動くのはなぜでしょうか？と
次の問題 じゃあ動くことわかりますけど
なんで動いてますかね
これが今までお釈迦様が悟り開くまで誰も考えてないんですよ
だから動くのはなぜでしょうか？ということは
なんで生きているのかっていうことなんです
知ってますかね 皆様頑張って生きてるでしょ？必死で
そんな必死で生きてるんだったら
私は質問しますよ なんで生きてるんですか？まだ考えたことはないんです
なんで生きてるんですか？これは目的知らないんだから元気じゃないんですよ
例えば子供に聞いたら
なんであんた勉強してるんでしょうか？と
いいえ 受験がもう試験がもうものすごい 1ヶ月間だよと
あと 2週間だよ そうすると目的があるんですよ
試験が 2週間で試験です
だから今必死で勉強してる
その場合は動けますよ
あー嫌だとか なんでこんな人生だとか
あんまり悩んだりしないんです
例えば スーパーに買い物に行く場合は悩んだりしませんね
買い物に行くんだぞと目的があるんです
しかし 何買おうかなと覚えてないとどうなりますかね？何買おうかなとメモを書いてないんです
スーパーに行かなくちゃといってスーパーに行ったところでどうなるんですか？派手に悩むんですよ
だってリストが書いてないんだから
キャベツ見たらいいキャベツあるんだ
じゃあ買おうかな あら
家にあったっけ？キャベツは
で じゃあうーん じゃあキャベツはあったと思いますから
じゃあ買わないことにしよう
でもやっぱり今日はキャベツはすごく新しいものだから買った方がいいんじゃないか
でもそうすると家なものキャベツ
いろいろ悩むんですよ
なぜでしょうか？目的がないんですね
それでキャベツやらチキンならいろいろ買ってる途中で
何かバスケットに入れて
いろいろ新しい服とかなんとか
あら これ安いんだ これも買ってやろうかなとか思ったりして
もうやっぱりこんな服買う時間じゃないか
また悩んだりしたり だからスーパーに行く場合はちゃんとこれこれこれこれ買いますと言った途端
ものすごい早い 行ってもうさっさっと買って
もうそれでお金払って出て気分がいいんです
あ 買い物しっかりしまったと
ただ単になんとか大阪で
じゃあまあ買い物に行くそうと言ったところで結構悩むんですよ
食べ物を見るたびに 食料を見るたびに
頭の中でレシピがぐるぐるぐるぐる回るんです
そうなってくると もう買い物できるわけじゃないんです
キャベツ見たら一つのレシピが回っちゃうし
ジャガイモのところでもう一つレシピが回っちゃうし
大根見たところでまた別なレシピが回っちゃうし
もうできんですよ だから一応目的作るんです
作ってしっかりするんです
しかし 人間はなぜ生きるのかっていうことは知らないんですよ
目的作ってないんです
だからですよ この世の中でみんな生きることに問題作ってます
失敗しています むちゃくちゃです
なんでもいいやと手当たり次第なんとかやって生きてるんです
そこでもっと生きたかったのに
もっとやりたかったこといっぱいあったのに
思ってる時点で あっという間に死んでしまいます
かわいそうに もっとやりたかったのにと思ったと
あんたは何やりたかったんでしょうか？ってわかってないでしょうに
だから生きている間に
これこれこれやりますよと決めておけば
それそれをやっておけば
OK 全部やって終わった
もう死んだっても大丈夫だというふうに言えますけどね
それはないんですよ 死ぬ時もキャーキャーと泣いたりするんですよ
あの時はね あのもう長男のあのお嫁さんがねとかね
まだいっぱい問題残ったままで死んじゃって
また幽霊になっちゃってきて
生きてる人を脅したりするんです
だから 今日はこの問題を解決しましょう
だから僕は科学的に見るんです
生きる目的は何でしょうか？という質問は使いません
科学的になぜ動くのかということなんです
生きる目的は何でしょうか？って言ったら
あんた生きて生きてるってこと知ってるの？とか聞きたくなるでしょう
ですから 生きていることは
今ちょっと前のスライドで研究しましたでしょ？動くこと
例えば心臓はいつ止まりますか？死ぬ時止まりますよ
そこまで止まりません
脳の動きはいつ止まりますか？死ぬ時止まります
だから我々体ができる前に
母親のお腹の中でたった 1個の細胞で現れるでしょ
父親から遺伝子もらって
母親から遺伝子もらって
1個の細胞になるんです
その時も動いています
精子も卵子も激しく動いています
なんかすごい工場のごとく動いています
卵子はちっちゃな細胞なのに
もう精子たちを必死で呼びかけるんです
こっちでいらっしゃい
だから頭の悪い精子たちが必死で動いてるんです
どうせ男性はずっと頭が悪いまんまですからね
しょうがないんですよ
で それで競争して まあ受精して
魂がというか 生命が誕生するんですよ
その時の動き 動き 動き
動き とにかく動き それ止まるのは死ぬ時なんです
ですから なぜ絶えず我々は動いてますかと皆様ご自分で聞いてみてください
皆様方も絶えず動いています
では 聞いたってわからないでしょ
では 実験してみましょう
呼吸を 3 分程度やめてみてください
呼吸は動きでしょ それを 3 分程度でやめてみる
どうなりますかね？耐え難い苦痛になるんです
やりすぎでは死にます
一番わかりやすい方は
この 3 分でもかかりません
吐き出して止めてみるんです
吐き出して止めてみると
1 分でわかるんです 動かなきゃ耐えがたい苦しみが現れます
だから動きいろいろありますよ
例えば歩いたり座ったりすることは適当でたまたまやってます
なぜならば それでは死に至ることはないんです
しかし 血液の流れ 脳の動き
心臓の動き 呼吸っていうのは
すーっと死ぬまで止まることをしないでやっていますよ
それ止めちゃうと冗談ででも死んじゃいます
それだけじゃない 死ぬのはどうでもいいんだけど
耐え難い苦痛なんですよ
死ぬのはいいんですけどね
時々いますね 結構あの
自殺してやるぞと言って海のところに行って
やっぱりやばいと あの
飛び降りるぞと言って
ビルの登ってから あー高いな
怖いなと で やめたりする場合も結構ありますよ
なんか富士山のところ
樹海とかなんとかありませんなっていう時
まあ人を自殺するとした舞台
そちらに行く場合がありますけど
そちらに行って やっぱり怖いな
これは怖いと言って帰る人も結構いるみたいです
自殺しようとしていた人が怖いとか痛いとか
なんでか 何考えてるんですかね
やっぱり問題はそちらにあるんですよ
結局は 死ぬということはそんな経験があることでもないし
しかし苦痛は経験しています
その苦痛は嫌なんです
そこは今も我々は味わっています
例えば吐き出す 吐いて呼吸をね
空気を吐いて止めてみると
1分でも体が震え始めるんです
ものすごい痛くなってくるんです
汗が出るんです それでも止めていると失神したり
死んだりするんです だからわかりやすいですね
動きを止めちゃうと死ぬんです
死ぬのはいいんだけど
必ずも痛いんです 耐えがたい痛みがあるんです
その他の動きも止めてみると耐え難い苦痛です
呼吸だけじゃないんです
例えば 皆様 今座っていらっしゃるでしょうに
この体 グニャグニャグニャグニャグニャグニャしないで
しっかりと筋肉の上に座ってみてください
どうなるのか 冗談じゃないでしょ？できませんね
ものすごい苦しいんです
だから座っていたっても行儀が悪くて足を伸ばすは
また曲げるは またあっち見るは
こっち見るは グニャグニャグニャグニャですよね
それが苦痛だからなんです
学校なんかね 小学校なんかはね
子供たちはもう全く授業を聞いていられませんね
グニャグニャグニャグニャ動いて動いて動いているのです
だからこちらはしっかりしなさいよとかね
落ち着いて話を聞きなさいよと言ったっても
向こうは痛いんだから
だから皆様 あまり気にしないでグニャグニャしてしながら聞いてください
そこで 例えば床に座る
椅子に座る 床に座ったら足が早く痛くなるんですけど
で 椅子に座っていて じーっと座っていると楽と思いますかね
どんどんどんどん苦痛になるんですよ
それでも絶対立てないで
1日 2日  3日  1週間ぐらい座っているとどうなるんですかね
ひどい病気になるんです
筋肉が衰えて衰えて大変なことになりますよ
例えば手を挙げるということは何のことないでしょう
こういうふうに手を挙げてじーっといるとどうなるんですかね
苦痛なんです お腹が空いてるとすごい苦痛でしょ
それだったらご飯食べるの楽しいでしょ
あれ 勘違いです ご飯食べることとか楽しいんだったらね
お腹が空いてると一口食べるとすごい楽しいでしょ
だったら 2口食べると 2倍楽しいでしょ
だって一口食べてこんなに幸せ感じるならば
2口食べると 2倍幸せ感じるそうだ
だったら 300口食べてみてください
300回幸せ感じれます
感じます じゃないでしょ
ものすごく気持ち悪くなって
吐いたりして大変です
もし胃が収縮して食べたものを出してくれなかったら死にますよ
食べただけでも死にます
だからお腹が空いても苦しいし
満腹になっても苦しいんです
ということは 肉体という物体の中で苦という感覚が入っています
この肉体の中に入れてますよ
苦しみというもの 苦という感覚が
それで我々どうするのかというと
対する 動いて苦しみをごまかす
例えば私も今ちょっと立っていたんだから
ちょっと苦しい そうすると座ってごまかすんです
それで座ってみると苦しいんでしょ？また立ってごまかすんです
座っても立っても 苦しいは苦しいんです
だから生きるということは
そうやって苦しみをごまかしちゃう
紛らわせる 例えば呼吸を吸って止まると耐え難い苦痛
その時は吐きます 吐いて止まると耐えがたい苦痛
そうすると吸います それで吸ったり吐いたり
吸ったり吐いたり 吸ったり吐いたりです
耐えやすくやっています
だから頭が悪いということは
生きることはなんてすごいでしょうか
なんて幸せでしょうかとかね
なんて尊いものでしょうかと
アホなことを言うんですよ
証拠はあるのかと聞きたいんですよ
我々は実際何をやっているのかというと
苦しみから苦しみへ飛び回っているんです
例えば お腹が空いている
苦しみは嫌だから食べる
満腹苦しみが嫌だから途中でやめる
座る苦しみが嫌になると立つ
立つ苦しみが嫌になると座る
一人でいることは苦しいと思っちゃうと結婚する
結婚して子供ができてうるさいと思っちゃうとどこかに逃げてしまうとかね
仕事がない人は その苦しみを仕事を見つかることでもう紛らわせる
それで仕事は苦しみだから
結局は仕事のないことも苦しいし
仕事があることも苦しいです
だって仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだから
そうするともう夜いっぱい酒飲んで
その苦しみを紛らわす
そうすると酒飲んだ苦しみが溜まっちゃって
朝なかなか目が覚めなくて
二日酔いで それが人生なんですよ
苦しみをごまかすこと
幸福ないんです 見つかるわけがないんです
生きることは苦を回転させて和らげることなのです
それが覚えてください
これこそ真理 事実です
世の中でなかったんです
お釈迦様がこれを発見したんです
生きるということは 聖書に書いているような面白い神話物語じゃないんだよ
屁理屈垂れ流して並べている
なんか面白い物語なんです
そんな面白い物語じゃない
生きるということは 肉体の中に苦という感覚があるんです
それでじっとしていられないんです
動く 動く 動く 動く 動物も動く
魚も動く アメーバも動く
他の生命も動く もし宇宙に他の生命がいるならば
動いていることだけです
それそちら 神様 女神がいるとするならば
別にどうってことない
動いているんです 幽霊がいると信仰するならば
まあいたってもどうでもいいんだけど
やっぱりいるならば動いているだけの話なんです
だから生命たるものは
どんな高次元であろうが低次元であろうが関係なく
ことごとく動くだけの話です
なんで動くのかというと
生きることの中に苦痛という苦というものが入っているんです
だから だから結論は生きることは苦である
それはお釈迦様が聖なる真理第一として説いたんです
生きることは苦であると
そうなってくるとどうなりますかね
立っていても座っていても結局は苦
お腹が空いても満腹になっても苦
幸福感 楽しみは錯覚 幻覚です
はい 例えばお腹が空いてる
ご飯食べる 楽しいですよ
あれ 幻覚ですよ だって一口食べて幸せなら
なんで二口食べたらそんなに美味しくないんですかね
お腹が空いている 自分の好物がある
それ好物ですから 一口食べるともうね
天国に行ったような幸せ感じるでしょうに
そうすると二口目はまた天国に行ったような
2倍 感じるはずでしょ？それはないんですよ
3回  4回  10回ぐらい食べるともう嫌になっているんです
もう苦痛を感じ始めているんです
その秘密はなんですかね
お腹が空いている場合は
ちょっと一口のご飯噛んで食べたところで原因消えちゃったんです
お腹が空く原因が消えた瞬間で結果消えちゃったんです
ですから 一口目で大量の苦をなくしちゃったんです
だから感じ出した幸せだと
2口目食べる場合は 消す苦しみがそれほどないんです
だからそんなに幸せ感じません
10回目食べるともうもう幸福感全然ないんです
だから消す苦しみがないんです
そうすると 食べる苦しみが自分の牙を出します
本音を見せます 本当は食べることも苦なんです
だから苦しくなるんです
一つその苦しみを別な苦しみで置き換えている間
幸福 楽しみ感じる それから感じるのは苦です
ちょっとこれ面白いんだから覚えておいてください
そんな難しくはないんです
立っていて疲れた人は座ると楽ですが
座っているとそれは苦になります
例えばこういう質問をしたら
1万円もらったら人は幸福感感じるのかと
答えられますかね  1万円をもらったら人は幸福感感じるのかと
それ答えることはできませんよ
また条件が必要です データが
その人どれぐらい苦しんでいるのかと
例えばその人 すっごい苦しいんですよ
苦しんでる 心臓発作を起こしてる
あるいは脳麻痺とか脳出血を起こしちゃって苦しんでいる
その人に 1万円あげたら苦しみは消えますか？消えませんね
だからその人は幸福感を感じません
1万円もらって幸福感を感じるのは
貧乏でお金がなくて 食べるものも買えなくて
その貧困で苦しんでいる人が 1万円もらったら幸福を感じるんです
心臓発作を起こして死ぬほどの苦しみを感じる人にとっては
もう見たくもないものなんです
なおさら怒るかもしれません
馬鹿にするんじゃないんだよと
だから  1万円もらったら楽しいでしょうか
ということは答えそれなんですよ
答えられません 楽しいでしょうかと
楽しいですよ 調べなくちゃいけない
相手が貧困の苦しみで悩んでいるならば
幸福を感じる 相手が億万長者なら
なんだこれというふうに全然なんとも感じない
だから幸福っていうのはそんな程度のもの
苦しみがないと幸福がないんです
だから皆様でも 例えばもうお金もなくて
もう 1週 1週間ももう何も食べることがなく
たった一回カップラーメンちょっと食べただけでという感じだったら
ちょっとした弁当もらっただけでもものすごい幸福感感じるんですよ
だから世の中に我々いう俗世間でいう幸福っていうのは苦しみのことなんですよ
苦がなければ幸福はないんです
だから 苦がすっぽっと消える幸福にお釈迦様は幸福だと言いません
例えば 私は人をぶん殴る
ぶん殴ったらその人はすっごく痛くなる
そうすると私すごい親切に
あ 痛いでしょうね じゃあ氷を当ててあげます
じゃあスプレーかけてあげますとか
じゃあこの この なんていうのは
このプラスター プラスターというのは何て言いますか
いろいろ貼るやつがありますね
これを冷却 冷やしてくれますから
これ貼ってあげますと
じゃあこれ巻いてあげますよとか
じゃあこれで水を飲んでください
一生懸命親切にしてあげて
じゃあ私はいい人間ですかね
ぶん殴ったのは悪いですからね
私が人をぶん殴って怪我させて
それからいい人間になってやろうと頑張っても意味がないでしょうに
それでもその人は殴ったのはあなたでしょうと
あんた殴らなかったら
そんなややこしいことをしなくても済むでしょうにと
ごまかさないで 殴ったことは悪いんだけど
ということになるんです
だから 俗世間でいう幸福が苦しみを作ってくれるんですよ
ご飯をおいしくさせてくれるのは幸福感なんです
だからですね ありがたいと思うことはできないんです
疲れた苦しみを寝ることで変える
寝る苦しみは起こる 起きることで変える
楽しく生きるとは 激しく
激しくですね 激しく様々な行動を変えて変えて動くことです
よく幸福だという人々は
まあ会社でちゃんとまあ月曜日から金曜日まで仕事に行くわ
日曜日は誰か友達と一緒のゴルフに行くわ
土曜日は友達と一緒のゴルフに行くわ
もう日曜日はもう午前中子供たちが遊んでいて
午後は誰かと一緒に外に出て食事をして
夜はなんとかしてとか
一生懸命動くことなんです
いわゆる激しく苦を苦を変える
それがもう人間いう幸福
楽しく生きることなんです
仕事をしたり 休んだり
テレビを見たり 音楽を聴いたり
本を読んだり 遊んだりして
人生ってなんて楽しいことでしょうと
幻覚の中で言っているんです
それが人生です これは本当のこと
ごまかしのない真理なんです
はい またポイント変えます
まあ単語変えるだけ 知るという単語を紹介します
知ることは生きることです
肉体にある苦の感覚は知ることです
例えば肉体に苦があるんですよ
それ知ってます だから喜ぶんです
だから苦という感覚があると同時に苦しいんだと知っている
その 2つが必要です 生命は自分の体を知る
外の世界を知る 生命ってそんなものなんですよ
例えばこの机が生命 ではありません
このテーブルが生命ではありません
なぜかというと 生命は周りのことを全然さっぱり知りません
自分のこともさっぱり知りません
だから私はこのテーブルを破っても
テーブルは知りません
破られた しかし 私はそうじゃないんです
私はこの環境のことを知っています
皆様方がいることを知っています
どんなところにいることを知っています
それだけじゃなくて 私は立っていること
立っていると体が痛くなってくること
それも知っています だから生きるということは知ることです
今 ２言葉紹介しました
生きることは動くことです
生きることは知ることです
身体は知ることはしないでしょ
お腹が空いたらそれを知る
食べた方が良いと知る
食べられるものを知る
手に取って食べる 食べていると知る
このすべてが知る機能の流れなのです
お腹が空いちゃうと知る
食べなくてはと知る それでいろんなものを見えますよ
いろんなものが見えたっても
これは食べられません
これも食べられません
これなら食べられると
これ知るのです だから安全ですよ
例えば人がお腹が空いたところで
私の手見たらあと言ってパクパク食べたらどうしますかね
そうしませんね あ これは食べられない
これなら食べられると知っています
それでそれ取ろうと口に入れようと
それ全部知ることでやるんです
取ったことは知る 運んだことは知る
口に入れたことは知る
噛む 噛むことは知る 飲み込む
それも知る それで空腹感消えていく
それも知る それで空腹がなくなったと思ったら
あの行動をやめる だから生きることっていうのは知る機能です
それで結論は知ることは生きることです
生きるとは 知る 知る 知る
知るの流れなのです 止まることなく知る機能が流れていくのです
知る機能によって体が絶えず動くという現象が起こるのです
知ると動く 知る 知ることと動くこと
なぜ知ることを別にしたのかというと
動かないで知ることもできますからなのです
それで知るということは
この精神の動きなんですね
我々が知っている動きは
心が引き起こす体の動きです
物体の動きです だから動き 2つ
例えば私は手を挙げると物体の手も動くのです
それで心も動くのです
感覚も動くのです 知ることも変わるのです
だから心が動いて体を動かしているのです
だからですよ 皆様のこの体の動きで心見えるのは
まあどこまでかというと
我々の顔の形 体の形 すべて色
何でもかんでも心が決めるのです
だから心の機能は隠せません
手を上げたり 下げたり
座ったりすることを全部心がやらせているんです
というわけで 動きが 2つあります
心の動きと体の動き 動きの意味
動くとは止まらない 変わる
変化する 一定しない 定まらないという意味です
これでテーマ変えます
動くとはどういうことですかね
止まらないってことです
定まらないってことなんです
動くこと 動く 動く 動く
動く 動く 一度動いたってまた動く
ですから知ることも動いています
知る 知る 知る 知る 知るきりがなく
知る 知る 知る機能 これ大変大事な意味があるんです
永遠不滅ではないんです
この永遠不滅っていうのは変な言葉です
物事は 絶えず動くだけ
だからどんな形になるかと決めたもんじゃないんです
太陽も絶えず変わっているでしょう
ずっと太陽が永遠不滅やと言えたもんじゃないでしょう
地球は永遠不滅やと言えたものじゃないんです
宇宙は永遠不滅だよと言えたものじゃないんです
何でも変わって変わって変わって変わっていくのです
お釈迦様がすべての物事は無常であると
この事実を語るんです
そこでブッダが教えるすべての物事は無常であるということは
たえず変化しているんだよと
たえず動いているんだよという科学的な事実なんです
それでお釈迦様の言葉で言えば
サッベーサンカーラアニッチャー
皆様覚えていると思いますよ
諸行無常という言葉は
これはパーリ語でサッベーサンカーラアニッチャー
あの日本で考えて諸行無常っていうのは変ですよ
なんとなく情状的に そんな面白くない話じゃないんです
これは科学的にものすごい一切生命
宇宙は全部動いていることを言っている
心の物質も無常なものです
生きることの怖さということ
で かなりスピードを上げないと時間に間に合わないんですけど
生きることは苦であるとわからないね
我々は勘違いしていて
生きることは楽しいんだと
これ怖いんですよ 例えば麻薬を取った人がなんて気分がいいんでしょうと
あれ 気分がいいんじゃなくて
脳が犯されてますよ そうするともう一回と楽しいんだと
もうもう一回と それで人生全部ダメになってしまうんです
そうやって麻薬中毒と同じく
我々は人生中毒なんです
生きることを楽しいと思っているんです
これが怖いんですよ 生きることは幸福であると逆さまに理解しているんです
しかし 経験しているのは苦なので
必死で生きることの中で楽しみを探し求めている
で 生きることは楽だったら何もしなくてもいいでしょ
でもなんで頑張ってるんですかね
みんな矛盾だらけ 生きることはなんて楽しいでしょうかって言いながら仕事を頑張ってるわ
家庭の中で一生懸命頑張ってるわ
もうものすごい忙しくて頑張ってるんです
あれ なんでや？と聞きたいんですよ
やっぱり矛盾ですよ 楽だったらね
ずっといた方がいいでしょうに
何もしないで なんで楽しいでしょうか？何もしないでボケーッとソファに座っていると楽しくないんです
だから結局事実は生きることは楽しいと口でごまかしても
心は知ってますよ 苦しいんだと
これをだから動け動けと言ってるんです
働け働けと言ってるんです
心は なんで働くのか 楽しくなるんだよと言ってるんです
働けば でもそれが それはまたごまかし
騙しで働いても楽しくならないんです
なぜかというと 生きることは苦
生きることの中で幸福を探すんだ
よ 見つからないんです
なんか分かりやすい例えないんでしょうかね
あ 書いてあると思います
探しても得られないのはのは
得られないのはこれだけです
さらに探す 例えば仕事がないと苦しいでしょ？仕事を見つかる
そうすると仕事が苦しいんです
だから 無職の苦しみをなくすために
仕事を見つかるという苦しみをもらったんです
確かにきっとその苦しみは消えたんです
でも その代わりに仕事があるという苦しみがあるんです
だからなんともしてないんですよ
一人でいるのは寂しいんだから結婚する
確かに一人でいる寂しさは消えちゃったんです
その代わりにもう一人と一緒に生活しなくちゃいけない
自分のわがままエゴはもう通らないという
他人に合わせなくちゃいけないという新しい苦しみが現れてくるんです
だからどこから借金すればいいかっていう話でしょうに
借金の金融会社がいっぱいあるんだと
山口という会社でもお金貸してくれる
もう田中という会社でお金貸してくれるとかね
もうまた村上という会社でもお金貸してくれるとかね
じゃあどんな会社から借りればいいか
どんな会社からでも借金でしょうに
利息は払わなくちゃいけないでしょうに
ひどいになりますよ そういうわけで
人生の中で我々は人は人生は火の中で氷を求めるようなもの
人の人生は 我々の幸福の探し方は
火の中で轟々と燃える炎の中で氷ないの？氷ないのかと探すんですよ
あるわけないでしょうに
その代わりに火に焼けて死んじゃいますよ
だから 俗世間の幸福の探し方はそのようなものなんです
火の中で氷を探す ですから
一般人は結婚してと幸福になろうと思う
子供を育てて 子供を作って幸福になると思う
金儲けたら幸福になると思う
誰もなった人がいませんよ
今まで なのに諦めませんね
それぐらい無知ですよ
例えば痩せたら幸福になると思う
痩せたんだからで幸福になりませんよ
体重減らせば幸福やとかね
期待したものが得られない時
なおさら悩む苦しみ 例えば金儲ければ幸福やと変な勘違いして金儲けるでしょ
儲からなかったらなおさら悲しいんです
儲かっても苦しいんですよ
だから儲からなかった
それでも苦しいんです
逃げる方法はないんです
子供が欲しいなと思ったら
子供を産めたら苦しいんですよ
それから一生束縛されちゃって
大変ですよ もうどうなることかさっぱりわかりませんだからね
生まれた母ちゃんが育てなくちゃいけないし
ちょっとでも失敗したらどうしようかとかね
大変な苦しみが生まれただけなんです
そこで子供が欲しいな
欲しいなのに生まれてこないと
それでも苦しいんですよ
よくできてますよ 生命のシステムが
苦しみからは逃げられません
どちらにしても同じことだと
あなた 崖から飛び降りて死ぬか
水に飛び降りて死ぬか
あるいは体に灯油をかけて火をつけて死ぬかと決めることです
どちらに決まっても同じことだからね
死ぬことには変わりありません
さらに楽を探したくない
そうするとさらに悔しくて探す
また期待が外れると このように性に対する執着が強化していくのです
どんどんとにかくやってみたい
とにかくやってみたいと
一回離婚してひどい目に遭ったら
今度こそしっかりした再婚して
しっかりした相手と再建してやるぞと思ったら
あの頭で決める相手だからね
また同じ結果になります
初めは人を間違って選んだでしょ
その能力でまた 2番目の人も選ぶんだから
別にどうったことはないんです
それでさらに悔しくなるんですよ
今度こそ成功してやる
今度こそやるというふうに
どんどん生きることに執着していくんです
人はもともとの苦しみをなくそうとして
限りない新たな苦しみを作るんです
結局 人生っていうのはもともと苦しいんです
我々は生きるということで
その苦しみの土台の上にたくさん限りのない苦しみを作るんです
この生き方は お釈迦様が卑しい探求と言うんです
我々は探すのは金を探している
結婚相手を探している
子供を求めている 財産を求めている
長生きを求めている 健康を求めている
全部卑しい探し方だと
だってそんなこと得ても苦しいんだよと
得なかったらまた苦しいんだよ
得ることできなかったら苦しいんだよと
例えば長生きできたら
長く生きる苦しみが待ち構えているんです
長生きしたいんだけど
長生きできなかったらものすごく苦しいんです
どちらにしたっても 苦しみは増えるだけなんです
それはパーリ用語でアナリヤカリエサナと呼ぶんです
あまり品格のない探求だと
無知な人の探求だと なぜ悩む？なぜ失敗する
それは知ることの問題です
生きること 知ることは生きることであるならば
問題が起こらないんです
例えば 生きることは知ること
知って行動する 知って行動する
それだったら OK です
しかし 問題です 知って行った行動は期待する結果は出さない
苦を別な苦で置き換えることは楽
幸福だと勘違いしていること
アヴィッジャモミヨが我々の悩み苦しみの原因になる
これちょっと難しくなっちゃった
あのね 喉が渇いている
それで私が水を飲んだら楽になるの知ってますね
それで水を飲んで水を飲む
渇いた状態は消える  OK でしょ
問題がありません もし人生をそのように行くならば
失敗しないでしょう お腹が空いた
それでご飯もある そこに砂もある
しかし 私は砂は食べられません
ご飯は食べられると知ってご飯だけ食べる
OK でしょ 安全でしょ
問題はありません しかし
人生っていうのは失敗の連続なんですよ
苦しみの連続なんです
ということは 知ることはおかしいんです
正しく知ってないんです
この人なら親切で優しくて
金の回りも良くて 結婚したら幸せになるだなと知っていて
結婚したら酷いになっちゃいましたよね
だからみんな間違って知ったんです
親切でないのに親切だと勘違いしちゃった
優しくないのに優しいと勘違いした
金回りがいい いいと そうじゃなくて誤魔化していたのに勘違いしていた
だから我々の知る世界は間違っているんです
だから人生そのもの 間違って勘違いしているんです
その基本的に間違っていることを知ること
間違っていることに仏教は無明というんです
それから本当はここで
半分ですけど どうしますかね
誤解することが生命にとって知ることなのです
我々の知るということは誤解なんですよ
いい例を言いましょう
科学者が世界一頭がいいと思っているでしょ
我々よりは 私たちにはすごいね
あれやこれやとか言ってくれるでしょう
でもあれ誤解ですよ 科学者でしょ？変なものをいっぱい作るの
原子爆弾とかね 大量破壊兵器とか
いかにして人を殺せるのかとか
そればっかりでしょ 科学者考えてるの
あるいは医学系で何かちょっと発見すると
これでぼろ儲けできるではないでしょうかと
人の救う気持ちは毛頭ないんです
だから科学者の脳細胞ももう間違ってます
誤解ですよ 全部 なんで人間なのに人間をいかにして殺せるのかと考えるんですかね
他人を殺して なんで自分が生きていきたいと思うんですかね
人間は殺すべきだと思っ
科学的に思うならば 自分自身も死ぬべきでしょうに
科学的だ 科学じゃないでしょう
で 俺たちが長生きする
でもあなた方は殺してやる
なんとおかしく 新しい医療技術開発するも
でも金持ちだけ それで健康になってほしい
金がなかったら死んでしまいと
死ぬもんか それって科学ですかね？科学的じゃないんです
だから科学者さえも誤解ですよ
承知と愚痴 知ることが生きることであるならば
正しく知るべきだというのは当然のことです
もしもすべての生命が正しく知ることはしない
認識は間違っているとするならば
どうなることでしょうか
そんなもんですね 知ることは生きること
正しくするならば OK です
しかし もし一切の生命を正しく知っていない
誤解しているならば大変でしょう
冗談でしょうと思われるかも
しかし 我々の人生はいかがなものでしょうか
失敗 悩み 苦しみなどの愚痴の結果です
だから生命はいつでも失敗する
人間なおさら失敗する
動物も大したことはないんだけど
人間ほど失敗しません
だから人間の方が愚痴がひどいんです
逆さまに知りたいと誰も思っていません
しかし 目 耳 鼻 舌 体 心に触れる情報を我々は瞬時に捏造して認識するんです
それはそれが問題なんです
えーとえーと ペンがある場所なんですけど
こっち側じゃないんですね
我々の目 耳 鼻に情報が入っちゃいますよ
入った情報を瞬時に捏造するんです
だから愚痴なんです たとえ話書いてます
ネズミの死骸を見る我々は瞬時に汚い
気持ち悪いと認識するんですよ
カラスさんがごちそうだと認識するんです
同じネズミの死骸でしょうに
私たちは気持ち悪いと認識する
カラスさんがごちそうだ
だからお互い様 勝手に認識したでしょ
物事をそれぞれの生命の都合によって変えて認識するんです
カラスにとってはごちそうという認識が都合がいいんです
我々にとっては汚い 気持ち悪いと思った方が都合がいいんです
例えばゴキブリ見たら気持ち悪いと思うでしょ？皆様
美味しそうにチキン食べてるでしょ
ニワトリさんがゴキブリ見たらどう思いますか？こんな考える暇もない
パクパクパクパク食べるんです
そこで気持ち悪いゴキブリ食べて太った鶏を我々美味しいと食べてるでしょ
豚さんがそうでしょうね
昔は放し飼いでね 昔は水洗便所なかったでしょ
ただ穴開けてあるだけ
後ろから豚が入りますよ
だから人は便用を出したら
豚さんがいて それを全部いただくんです
それで豚がどんどんみるみるうちに増えるんです
そうすると なんて美味しいでしょうかと
豚を殺して食べるんです
早いんですけどね 直接
そうはしませんね だから私は何を言いたいかというと
私が勝手にネズミの死骸は気持ち悪いと思っても
カラスにとっては別な認識
だから 都合によって目に入ったデータをねつ造したんです
人間同士でも同じものを見て聞いて
同じ認識が生まれることはありませんよ
我々も同じものを見て同じ感じが生まれません
同じ音楽を聴いても 同じ感想は生まれません
ある人の好物はすべての人の好物ではありませんね
カエルは好きですか？嫌いですか？どうですか
カエルを見る時 生まれる目の感覚が滑らかなら
カエルのこと好きですよ
人はいるですよ カエルが嫌いという人もいるし
カエルはすごい好きだと思う人もいます
私はデリカカエルのことすごい好きなんです
見ると捕まりたくなるんです
捕まって遊びたくなるんです
どうも可愛くてたまらないんです
で ここら辺のカエルのあの顔のここら辺を触ったりすると
目が出っ張ってるんですよ
あれがピッと中に入るんです
これは面白いこと あの耳があるところとか
指で触ったりすると 目がチンと中に入ったりするんです
で まあカエルにとって危害がないなとわかったら
すぐ落ち着いてますよ
逃げたりもしない だからまあ
私はカエルが好きですけど
カエルが嫌いな人もいる
なんでその好き嫌い生まれるんでしょうかというと
カエルを見ると目で感覚が生まれるんですよ
その感覚は滑らかであまり苦しくはないんです
それだったらカエルは好きや好きやでねつ造するんです
可愛い可愛いとねつ造するんです
目の感覚が激しかったら
カエルのことは嫌い いきなり目の感覚ってなっちゃうと
カエルのことを嫌いと思っちゃいます
だからカエルは好きですか？嫌いですか？という答えに
質問に答え その答えなんですよ
好きですったって全然飲むこともないんです
そういうことで 自分とエゴという話に入ります
それでこの 我々はねつ造する
自分の都合の情報 を見ると私が見た聞くと
私は聞いた 考える 聞いた
考えが起こる 私は考えたということになるんです
感覚がなければ このような私という現象は起きません
そこで私が見た 私が聞いた
私が感じたと 私が私が出てくるんです
これ感覚ですよ 感覚なかったらそんな変なことは言えませんよ
感覚は瞬間で変わるものです
和菓子を食べてお茶を飲むということがあるでしょ
味覚は瞬間で変わらないと何の味かとわからないんですよ
なんでお茶飲むときに和菓子食べますかね
お茶だけではおいしくないんです
和菓子だけではおいしくないんです
そこで味を変えるんですよ
特に和食の場合は あの品数がありすぎでしょ
西洋の食事と違うでしょ
ものすごい品数 あれはなんでしょうかというと
味を変えるんです 見る感覚変えるんです
触れも感覚変えるんです
だから感覚っていうのは瞬時に変えて
変えて変えて変えて変えていくんですよ
そう変えないと苦しいんです
例えば 日本の料理は世界で美味しいだと皆様偉そうなことを言うんだけど
なんであんなたくさん品数使うんですかね
だったら大量にご飯盛ってもらって
ご飯だけ お新香もなく
大根じゃなくてたくあんもなく食べてみてください
その時は食べられませんよ
だから白いご飯を食べる時はお茶をつけたりとかね
何かふりかけを入れたりとか
塩をかけたりとか いろいろ味を変えるんですよ
だから感覚は瞬間 瞬間変わる
感覚に私 私と言う だったら私
私という自我が瞬間 瞬間変わるはずなんです
音楽を聴いてみましょう
激しいスピードでたくさんの音が流れて消えていく
音楽とはそういうものです
聴覚も音と一緒に変化しないなら
音楽の音を認識することはできません
音楽を聴くと思ったってでも
音楽というのは激しく音を変化することです
それ耳の感覚を激しく変化しないと聞こえない
しかし 音楽だとするのは
聞いた人の捏造した認識で
犬に猫に鳥に その他の生命に
その音は音楽ではありません
音楽だと私たちは捏造するだけで
本当は音だけです だから同じ音楽を聴いても
猫には音楽じゃない 犬にもそれは音楽じゃない
鳥たちにもそれが音楽じゃないんです
音楽っていうのは人間の捏造
だから鳥が自分の相手を呼ぶ
雄鶏が雌鶏を呼ぶ 木の上で止まって
あれはこっちいらっしゃいという声ですよ
私はこちらだよと こっちだよと
もうオスの鳥が言ってるんです
それでメスがそちらに飛んでいくんです
はい わかりました 我々その声を聞いてね
なんて鳥のさえずり声ってなんて美しい音楽でしょうかとかね
あれは人間の捏造ですよ
だからオスの鳥がこっちおいでよ
こっちおいでよと何回も鳴くと
メスがうるさい もうわかったよ
来るぞと言って出ていくだけの話ですよ
だから鳥たちにはそれは音楽ではないんです
さえずり声とかなんとかじゃないんで
さえずりとか何でもないんです
でも我々にとっては なんて綺麗な音でしょうかと
瞬間たりとも一定しない感覚の流れに
私 自我 エゴ 自分 自己だと合成した
捏造した認識が生まれるんです
だから自我っていうのは捏造です
これが瞬間変わる感覚のことです
体の感覚で外の情報を知るが
一切の情報を自分の都合で捏造するので
私が知るものは他人が知らない
知り得ないということになります
結局は私が知る世界 他人が知らない
捏造だからね 感覚から
知の働きから自分だけの殻を作るんです
だから私たちは自分だけの殻に閉じ込められて苦しく生きてるんです
はい これまでの整理ですね
私の世界が変わる データを私の都合で合成する
捏造する それが私が知るということになる
私が知る 他人は他人の都合でデータを合成したり
捏造したりするから 必ず私が他人と違う存在になる
私が知ることは私が捏造する
相手が知ることは相手が捏造する
ですから 私と相手が変わるんです
だから私が同じがおいしいというと
他の人が刺身がおいしいと言うんです
それぞれ捏造の世界違うんです
それで我々は自分と他人が違いますよと言ったりするんです
で 例えば私が優しい言葉を使うと
もう一人の人が乱暴な言葉を使う
それで私がこの人は嫌なんだな
違うね 乱暴な言葉を使うんだから言って
自分と違う人間だと思って差別する
だからもう可哀想です
我々知るだけで他人と変わった世界を作るんだから
私が生きるために 苦をやりながらためのために
物事を知ったり行動したりする
しかし それが期待通りにいかないのですよね
それで私が生きるために知っているということよりも
難しいと言います 飛ばします
目耳に話した心に入るデータが外の世界のもので
私に管理できません 問題は
私が生きるためにいろんなことを知りたいんだけど
入るデータが自分にはどうすることもできないんですよ
目 耳 鼻に入るデータは
データを好き嫌い 面白くないという基準で評価するんです
それでむさぼり 怒り 無知が心に起こるんです
こういうことが起こるんです
私が知りたいんです 外の世界を知るんです
しかし 外の世界は私の勝手じゃないんだからね
目に何が入るか 私にはどうすることもできない
生えるは生えるは生えるはデータが入る
データが私は好き嫌い
面白くない 好き嫌い 面白くないに分ける
耳にいろんな音を入る
入るたびに私が好き嫌い
面白くないと分けるんです
口にいろんな味が入るんですよ
そうすると好き嫌い 面白くないと捏造する
分析する それで頭の中で貪瞋痴という仏教でいう巨大な毒が三毒が生まれるんです
これでどうしようもないんでしょうね
例えば 私に見えるものを管理できれば好きだけできいられますよ
例えばこのホールはいいんだけど
天井はちょっとそんなに美しくないんですね
では 天井は虹色になってくれと
俺が虹色が好きだからって変わりますかね？変わります
ある天井を見るしかないんです
それでまあ壁とか見ると
これ武道館だからね そんなに美しく作っているわけじゃないんですね
ちょっともう と変革を作った方がいいなと思ってもどうしようもないんです
だからあるものを見るしかないんです
だから私の心の中で好き嫌い生まれてしまうんです
はめられています 好きなデータが絶えないこと
嫌なデータがなくなることを期待するが
外の世界の管理はできません
だから 美しいものだったらもっと欲しいと思ってますけど
世界はそううまくはいかない
嫌いなものを消えてしまえと思いたいんだけど
消えてくれないとかね
だから期待通りに行かないんですよ
人生は 外のデータによって振り回される人になる
ですから 我々一人一人が環境によって振り回されているんです
だから こちら住む大社に来たら
環境はいいんだから 皆さんはどうかわかりませんだけど
ああ いい環境だなと 大阪のね
街の真ん中でね 気分が良かったんです
だから環境に振り回されたんです
これはどうしようもない
こうなっているんです
欲や怒り 無知という感情で世界に対して対立したり
世界を変えようとしたりする
人間 バカなことするんですよ
世界を変えようとするんです
自分の勝手に 絶対変わりませんよ
自分の勝手に だから苦しいんですよ
例えばリンゴは自分好きな味にしようかなと思っちゃうと
リンゴの農家が何年も苦労して研究するんですよ
うまくいかないんですよ
失敗 失敗 失敗して やっと一つ出来上がっちゃうと
もう大成功だと報告して
その名前をつけたりして
ふじとかなんとかとかのリンゴを売ってるんです
だからトマトがもともとは匂いがあって
すごい酸っぱい酸っぱいものでしたからね
レモンとそれほど変わりはないんですよ
自然のトマトは これは嫌だからね
それを改良して改良して改良して
今の体に悪い 健康にも悪い甘いトマト作っているんです
それで元のトマトを研究して
これはとても体にいいもので
ミネラルたっぷり入ってますよと
ビタミンたっぷり入ってますよと言ってから
ミネラルもビタミンも何も入ってない
砂糖しか入ってないトマトスープで食べてるんです
食べて健康になりました
今日トマトも食べましたと
でも期待通りの結果にはなりませんね
そういうことです 健康になりたければ改良しない
しない ちょっと臭みが入ってるトマト食べなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 我々バカだからそれでも頑張るんですよ
世界を変えようと 花の色を変えようとするわ
花の形を変えようとするわね
大変です それもまたできることではありません
失望感で失敗した 能力はない
運命が悪い ついていないなどの気持ちで新たな悩み
苦しみが生じる それでトマトを改良しようとリンゴを改良しようとか
もう世界変えようと頑張るとうまくいかないでしょ？うまくいかないのはたくさんでしょ
そうすると失敗してああ失望しまった
例えば交際交際だけで結構失望するでしょ
自分の期待希望通りにいかないんだからね
だから希望通りに世界をいじろうとすると
なおさら失望感 期待はずれ
失敗感 それから能力ない
能力ないとか惨めになったり
ついてないとか 運が悪い
占ってみようとか 占い師に頼んでみよう
この頃運が悪いとか いろんなことを考えちゃうんで
いろんな苦しみを作るんです
これは私の世界 生きることは本来苦なのに
それに間違った方法で対応するからです
対応するから 存在苦の存在苦の上に期待が外れる苦
失敗する苦 嫌な人と出会う苦
好きな人が離れる苦 他人と比較して惨めになる苦
他人を軽視して攻撃して他人から受ける非難などの苦
努力が叶わない苦 努力できない苦
頭の妄想のせいで物事を把握できない苦
他人に負ける苦などなどが作るんです
どうですか？生きるということは
面白いでしょう これですよ
生きるということは 苦を作るは作るは作るは作るよ
キリがない これが私という世界なんです
私にできることは 生きる苦を増やすことだけです
結局 私にできるのは生きる苦を増やすことだけです
私は何をしても それが生きる苦に新たな苦を付け加える結果になるんです
頑張ってみてください
新たな苦が足して足していくだけ
頑張らなかったらそれがまた苦なんです
うん 私とは愚痴でできている世界です
あれ愚痴だからですよ
結局 私の行為行動は愚痴から決めたものです
幸福になりたいという気持ちがあるが
気持ちだけあるが 実際に行っているのは苦を増やすことです
だから間違った判断 お医者さんが診断を間違ったら患者さんがどうなりますかね
もう聞かなくてわかるでしょう
だから我々は自分の人生いつでも間違った判断するんです
検査はして間違った判断出すんです
それでお医者さんが患者さんの病気をものすごい間違った判断していたならば
患者さんが死ぬんです
苦しむんです それに我々は自分に対して愚痴で間違った判断をしているんだから
幸福になりたいけど なるのは苦痛
これが私です それでお釈迦様がこの苦しみをなくす道を教えるんです
愚痴を承知に変えて ありのままの事実を発見することです
承知ということ 見るもの
聞くもの 感じるものなどを捏造しないで
自分で解釈判断しないで
そのまま受け入れてみるんです
そのまま認識してみるんです
これ修行なんです ちょっとの時間
捏造をやめてみるんです
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
感じるもの そのままに見て
聞いて 感じて じっと何も考えないで判断しないでいるんです
わかりやすく言えば 妄想しないで
思考しないで データをありのままに知ることになります
耳に音が聞こえるんだけど
鳥のさえずりやらね カラスの声だとか
子供が遊んでるとか そんな変な妄想しないで音だけ聞いてるんです
そうすると瞬間瞬間感情が変わること
聴覚が変わること 音の瞬間瞬間変わること
発見するんです 自我がないことを発見する
それでたちまち悟りに達します
それで苦しみが消えます
それで初めて自分という実体はなりたてない
すべては瞬間に変わっていく現象の現象のみだ
欲望に怒りに値しないものだとわかるんです
頭の中で妄想しないで
捏造しないで ただいるだけ
ただいるだけで悟ります
何もしない 何も思考しないで
捏造しないで ただ見て聞いて感じているんです
そうすると物事が変化していくんだ
それだけじゃない 自分という感覚も変化しているんだわ
なるほど 自分がいないんだから
まあなんのことないんだって
そこで怒る必要はない
何に怒るのかと 変わってる
変わってしまうもの怒る必要ないでしょ
消えて消えちゃうんだからね
執着の値しないなどが発見する
執着の値しないではなく
初めからもう執着できないものだと発見することで悟りに達する
そこで執着を捨てろとよく言いますけど
捨てる必要ないんですよ
初めから執着できないんですよ
物事は勘違いだけ だからそれをわかったら心は悟りに達するんです
正知が現れたら すべての問題が間違いが消える
承知が瞬間現れたら十分です
これ全部間違いが消えます
すべての苦しみが消えるのです
妄想ということ 我々の認識そのものが真理ではないが
学問 知識 技術 技術など生きる上で必要なものがたくさんあります
あの認識 知識っていうのはもうどういったことない間違いですよ
しかし 勉強しなくちゃいけないしね
いろんなものを学ぶなくちゃいけない
それは生きるために必要ですよ
牛は学問がなくても生きていられますが
人間は無理ですね 学問は正しくないよ
科学者の知識も間違ってます
変です しかし 勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
牛は別に物理化学知らなくてもちゃんと生きていられます
知識に基づいて行っている行動さえも失敗したり間違ったりするのに
人間はよく妄想するんですよ
皆様は学校で大学で学んだ知識さえも失敗しますよ
間違いだらけだから その上
我々はなおさら妄想までする
これって大変です 妄想とは現実から離れた何の役にも立たない思考の無駄な回転です
頭は論理的な有意義な思考に使う時間がわずかです
大半妄想に浸っているのです
我々は 1時間取っちゃうと大事なこと考えるためにはもう 30 秒も使わない
残り時間全部  59 分 30 秒
妄想に使う 無駄ですね
時間が だからこのスライド作るために知ってますか？そう
大体 45 分か 1時間あたりですよ
かかった時間が で妄想しないんです
さっさと仕事するんです
ほとんどの行動は妄想から決めるので断然的に悪いんです
妄想してやるものは断然的に悪いんです
例えば あの人私のことを恨んでるでしょうねとかね
証拠ない場合は何もしないでください
恨んでると思って何かやったら
これ断言的に悪いことになる
間違いない 悪い結果になるんです
着々と幸福へ それで終わりです
この話は 妄想を減らすと同時に能力が向上する
俗世間の苦しみが減っていく
仕事は簡単 妄想を減らしていくんです
そうすると能力が向上する
時間が余っちゃう そうすると疲れません
苦しみ減る さらに正知に挑戦して
知識 概念 思考も超えて真理をありのままに見られたら
究極的な幸福悟りに達するのです
そういうことで お釈迦様が着々と幸福になる道を教えているのです
仏道は始めた瞬間から人を具体的に幸福へ導くものです
で 話は終わりです